you ready oh yeah
[Music]
attila the huns
sword of mars
yes known as the scourge of god attila
the hun was one of the most feared
conquerors in history the leader of the
hanukk empire his group of nomadic
tribes wreaked havoc across europe
during the 5th century though he was
once a great ally to them he played
roman territories sacking major cities
like constantinople legend states that
attila was given the sword of mars by a
herdsman filling a prophecy and a direct
sign from the roman war god mars of his
divine rule
the lethal weapon featured a curved
handle with a spear point tip that gave
it exceptional control allowing for
accurate and brutal thrust after
attila's death in the year 453 the
hunnic empire quickly dissolved however
the story of attila's many conquests
still live on through the television
mini-series attila all right bladesmiths
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will deliver
killing blows on this but the sex dummy
randy up first you ready i am let's do
this
nice
all right let's talk about your sword of
mars here first up the damascus pattern
you have here is gorgeous perk the
weapon design is very aggressive for
thrusting and slashing now your handle
construction if you reverse this
it'll be easier to have something to
lock onto the fact that the flare is
right here forcing my hand to open up if
i want to marry into the hilt this is a
very sharp weapon the tip pierces
all the way through cuts on the way out
it's pointy and scary and
it will kill right here good job all
right dan it is your turn you ready oh
yeah let's do this i was hoping the kill
test would be a dummy i know heads will
roll
all right dance talk about your weapon
here i love the balance of your blade
when i go forward it's not hard to pull
back to go in again for another kill now
your handle construction it's curved
enough to where it doesn't want to fly
out of my hand it's got a good grip and
control for this your edge allows for
very deep cuts into the abdomen right
there the only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a bend when it's
chopped into the spine
but
your weapon sir will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry and through
his military campaigns he revolutionized
the use of horse in military conflicts
so to test the strength and durability
of your blades i'll be chopping into
these horse skulls
randy you're first you ready i guess so
[Applause]
wow
okay so
right off the bat the biggest thing is
that this section from right about here
to here
has lost its edge
there's a couple of small
rolls
blade's still straight it's all in one
piece still solid nicely done it's a
very strong bite thank you all right dan
are you ready no but let's do it
everybody says that
at the guard
[Music]
okay so
before we get to the obvious i really
like the design of your blade it's got a
great weight to it had a really good
feel in my hand the balance was really
nice
see all that space around your tang
with that room for that blade to move
inside the guard it could just create so
much stress that it cut loose right
there at the corner if it were all tight
there would be any stress there's no
discoloration here so it's not that
there were it was a crack here before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but obvious flaw
dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test which means that we
can no longer test it
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand
and then please leave the forge
it hurts but my sword breaking it's
gonna be a reminder that i have to push
harder and be better randy the strength
and efficiency of your weapon in the
kill test have earned you the title of
forged and fire champion and a check for
how much i don't know that's right ten
thousand dollars good job brother i won
foraging car it's reality how do you
feel good to be a champion and be
recognized as a good blade smith is all
real good
this is my happy and excited face not
that sir hey if he didn't recognize it
jason don congratulations you've made it
into the third round of this competition
we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate an iconic weapon from
history
that weapon is
the scissor
wielded by gladiators in ancient rome
the scissor was an ideal weapon for the
bloody battles that ensued at the
coliseum arena the contour of the sharp
crescent-shaped blade was optimal for
slashing and stabbing while the armor
encasing the forearm offered protection
gladiators who used the scissor were
also known as cesares they could swiftly
brandish the weapon in the heat of
battle due to its surprisingly
lightweight the dual block and cut
capabilities of the scissor free the
user's other arm for another weapon or
shield giving the user the advantage of
multiple ways to attack all right
gentlemen this is the sharpness test to
test the sharpness of your edge i'm
going to attack our sandman here several
times see how they do
jason you're up first are you ready for
this yes sir all right let's do it
[Music]
all right
the handle feels really good in my hand
but the shape of your blade
not being as deep a crescent
made it a little bit more difficult to
slash
all in all solid and it's got a good
look
nicely done thank you all right don you
ready i'm ready
don i like the way this is set up
tighter around the arm
right here at my hand
my knuckle is just pounding into the
side
you can see it slashed pretty easily on
the arm and then on the forward punch
didn't quite get a slash i was looking
for all in all though did the job thank
you next up i'll give you the dug
bladesmiths this is a kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do i will take your scissor and i
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy jason you're first you
ready let's do it let's do this
[Applause]
first off the minute i put my hand in
your handle it's not
directly in line with my fist so it's
slightly off
but as you can see i can still wield the
weapon the laceration was deep into this
cavity right here so you've got a very
sharp blade the hook you have
penetrated right into the heart on the
backhand draw it lacerates and guts
everything out and disembowel
this ballistics dummy
your weapon sir
will kill
good job sir thank you
don
your turn let's have some fun let's do
this
[Music]
good
jon let's talk about your weapon
what i like about your weapon is that
it's in line with the handle on the
initial cut here it lacerated right
through there and in this backhand hook
your edge is deep to go in here and
right into that cavity your weapon will
kill thank you i think we're running
neck and neck and it feels pretty
amazing but of course i wish i was
further ahead of don i wish his would
just spontaneously explode all right
gentlemen this is the strength test now
the scissor was used in gladiatorial
combat for both attack and defense now
to test the strength and durability of
your weapon we'll clamp them into our
mechanical device here the blade is
going to come down and strike the
armored cuff of your weapon twice and
then your weapon is going to be launched
into this breastplate jason i've already
got yours strapped in so you ready to go
let's do it okay
just the slightest roll
it's not deformed beyond being sharp and
then you can see where the sword came
down and hit it
caused a bit of deformation and then i
think we were pushed just a little
further offline
right in here
it looks like it kind of
waffled just a bit
but everything is still tight still
sharp nicely done
thank you so don you ready i'm ready all
right let's get you strapped in
so looking at this i can i'm having a
hard time finding where the sword hit it
and there's one teeny little mark
you know the blade's still tight on that
edge it's still a razor blade there's no
rolling at all very well done it's nice
thank you
[Music]
bladesmiths you've worked very hard to
recreate weapons that we've never seen
here in the forge before however in this
competition there can only be one forest
and fire champion
and that champion is
[Music]
don congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion yeah
thank you
jason unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your
scissor
i spent five days making something i've
never made before i went up against a
guy who builds armor quite often i held
my own against him i'm pretty proud of
that fact
i loved every minute of this experience
don congratulations you were the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
that check for 10 grand how do you feel
right now man i feel fantastic it feels
great to be a fortune fire champion
ten thousand dollars i like to get
something nice for my wife we kind of
had a little fun you know making jokes
at each other about texas versus
oklahoma yeah i'm glad to see texas came
out on top
the egyptian kapesh
dating back to 2500 bc the kapesh was a
curved sickle sword adopted by egyptians
from the canaanites it was used to
execute their enemies as an infantry
weapon and also as a symbol of the
authority of their nobles
the unique shape of their curved blades
meant they could be used to hook a
shield snag an opponent's leg in an
attempt to trip them or even tangle an
opposing weapon
the weapon's distinctive design makes
the kapesh easily recognizable in
television series such as game of
thrones planesmiths it is said that the
historic design of the kopesh evolved
from a battle axe its edge was so sharp
that it said it could cut through just
about anything to test the sharpness of
your weapon i will see how well it cuts
through a sandbag
sugarcane and a rope salem you up you
ready yes sir
[Music]
well salem it definitely is easy enough
to cut through a sandbag cut through
sugar cane
but the forward weight being a little
bit tip heavy was a little bit harder to
slice through on the upward stroke but
definitely it's a very sharp weapon
this sir will cut good job thanks
craig you're up you ready yes sir
[Music]
i'm just disappointed that it wouldn't
cut the rope
[Music]
well craig
it cut to a sandbag cut all the way
through three sugar canes but the same
idea on an upward swing for the test it
did lacerate the rope but it didn't cut
through
but overall
it will cut
now it's time to move on to the kill
test
to test the functionality and lethality
of your blade i will attempt to rip off
the shields then deliver killing blows
on this ballistic dummy let's see how
much damage your weapon can do salem
you're up you ready all right
the hook on your tip does allow to rip
off the shield
the edge you have right here cause some
serious damage
enough to cut all the way through the
belly here at the same time i've cut
through all these bones from the
clavicle through the ribs
this sir
the keels
craig it's your turn you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
well craig
what i like about your particular hook
design over here is that as you puncture
twist and rip out everything that you
have in there will hook and come out
with it
the edge cut all the way into the bone
and broke these ribs to stir them this
sir
will kill
thank you
next up is a strength test dave
gentlemen what i'm going to do to test
the strength of your weapons is take
seven blows against these animal femurs
salem you're up are you ready great
now salem in examining your weapon we
noticed a small delamination on the back
of the blade
i was not expecting that i'm just hoping
that the edge stays hard so we're going
to keep an eye on that through the
testing and we'll see if it opens up
[Music]
well say on that
that did a job on those bones now
there's a little bit of deflection on
your blade
but that back mark didn't open or split
at all
now you can see i went through two of
those bones and was well into the third
well done thank you so craig it's your
turn you ready let's do it all right
[Music]
shhh well craig you can see
a lot of chips right there in the impact
zone
the first few blows against those femurs
it started cutting really nicely broke
through the one but as we started to
lose edge here with those chips and
deflections it just stopped cutting and
it was more a bludgeoning impact blow
but i felt it really cut well when i was
swinging it all in all nice design i
like your handle construction
and it's definitely a chopper
so gentlemen
good job
salem craig there can only be one forged
and fire champion
salem
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations
good job thank you
good job to you too
craig unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
all right thank you this experience was
harder than i thought it was gonna be i
need about three gin and tonics and i'm
just gonna make the bad man in the back
of my head go away
salem it's safe to smile now because
you're the fortune fire champion the
recipient of ten thousand dollars
congratulations fullers on that blade
just really bring that pattern out i
think that's really nice touch
that's just crazy
it's going to take a while to sink in
kind of stunned right now
the roman gladius
the word gladius means sword in latin it
was also adopted as the name for those
who would fight each other to the death
for the entertainment of the imperial
crowds as depicted in the hollywood
blockbuster gladiator
the gladius was the primary weapon of
the roman legionary with a fearsome
v-shaped tip for thrusting and stabbing
and a double razor sharp edge for
slashing and slicing
originally a spanish weapon the romans
were so impressed by its simple design
and lethal effectiveness they adopted it
as their own and used it to help them
establish one of the greatest empires
the world has ever known
for the slice test i will take your
weapon and slash through branches vines
and sugar cane so different layers
different consistencies jamie you're up
first are you ready i am
definitely a good impact weapon only
thing was at the end as you're doing
more shots it starts to rotate with a
very rounded handle but it is sharp and
for this test
it can cut
mareko you're up next are you ready i'm
ready
very light on the hand
very sharp
a lot of the sugar canes have very clean
cuts despite being surrounded by these
branches the handle construction felt
secure in my hand
it will cut
good job thank you very much
now it's time for the kill test to test
the lethality of your weapon i will
slash cut and stab this ballistics dummy
that is dressed like a gladiator in the
roman era
jamie you're up are you ready absolutely
[Music]
well that lacerated all the way through
to the bone destroyed the clavicle
completely
disemboweled here
thrust went through
and that's definitely a kill shot all
the way into the spine
this will kill good job thank you
mareko you're next you ready i'm ready
that's all the way through
disemboweled on that pass
throat all the way to the spine
it will kill
good job thank you
now to test the strength of your weapon
your gladius will be placed on this
dynamic testing rig
this rig is calibrated to deliver a
strong blow similar to a roman
legionnaire from his era
your gladius will strike our gladius
that is made of 1055 high carbon steel
three times or until one of the blades
break
jamie your gladys is already loaded into
this ring are you ready i am
in three two one engage
[Music]
engage
engage
well your edge held all the way through
little indentations there nothing major
this crushed right through the sword so
this would have broken the soldier's arm
that's a strong sword good job thank you
okay miracle you're up
i'm ready
my biggest fear is that it's gonna make
contact and it's just gonna break in
three two one engage
engage
three two one engage
it held up
more scratches to the blade
that is a strong blade sir
congratulations thank you very much
jamie mareko
there can only be one champion
jamie
you are the forged empire champion
congratulations
thank you
mareko your blade did not make the cut
morocco i honestly love your sword but
functionality is the key and just cannot
overlook that handle coming apart reckon
please surrender your weapon
definitely sucks
but um it feels really good to have had
a chance to challenge myself and to step
outside my comfort zone and do a good
job at it
jamie congratulations you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars thank you
do you feel like fortune favorite bulb i
do i feel like i took some chances and
those decisions helped me win this
competition for me it's all about the
detail the choice of materials the way
you laid it out which is really really
nice work thank you i feel good it's ten
thousand dollars definitely helped me
out maybe we might find some time for a
little vacation somewhere here or there
we'll see we'll see
[Music]
the morrow chris
the chris came into existence around
1361 a.d in the kingdom of majapahit
east java
believed to be the primary weapons
wielded by asian warriors its
distinctive wavy blade creates a wider
wound during combat causing the victim
to quickly bleed to death
the hilt is viewed as a work of art and
is often carved in meticulous detail
from precious wood
gold or ivory in popular culture the
chris can be seen in the video game
mortal kombat the unique design of a
morrocus is even made more distinct by
its fluid wave-like edges it can thrust
but its primary purpose is slashing and
chopping to test your chris's ability to
perform according to its ancient design
i will use it to chop and slice against
these moving targets
mace you're up first are you ready sure
[Music]
nice
nice balance nice recovery allows you to
just move with a blade
good job thank you
mary you're next you ready certainly am
[Music]
well murray
the balance of this blade allows me to
chase an attack and will come with me on
the recovery to go to another attack it
will stay with me it doesn't go away
from me
it'll slice good job thank you
to test the lethality of your chris i
will take your weapon i'm gonna strike
into this animal carcass
mace you're up first you ready yes sir
well
it cut cleanly through the spine all the
way through the meat in one big
sweeping slash
it will kill
good job thank you very much
where are you up next you ready yep
when cutting through there was a slight
drag in the feel of the cut but it did
cut very cleanly through it's a very
very sharp
blade they will kill
bamboo is a very durable material ounce
four ounce it is stronger than concrete
brick or wood to test the strength of
your crisp i will deliver four strikes
into the bamboo to see how well your
weapon stands up mace you're up
[Music]
welp
no damage to the blade sir
it chopped nicely
but a couple of times over there it
didn't want to fall out of my hand just
because it's so heavy on the blade but
nonetheless looks like your edge did
hold up
excellent mary you're up next you ready
yes i am
[Music]
okay murray looks like your blade edge
held up with the chops it almost clearly
sliced all the way through
but there is now an issue that we're
looking at with your blade
i think there might be a little bend
here caused from chopping into the
bamboo
but other than that
it still has a very sharp edge the
strength of the blade held up
good job thank you
gentlemen you have both done immaculate
work however
in this forge there can only be one
winner of ten thousand dollars
mace
you are the forged and fire champion
yes congratulations
thank you very much job man thanks very
much happy for you murray
unfortunately your chris did not make
the cut
murray i find that weapon absolutely
beautiful and comfortable
but
the fact that there's a soft core in
there somewhere and that it picked up a
bend where your opponent's blade did not
that was the deciding factor and that's
why we had to let you go
murray please surrender your weapon
while there's always a disappointment
when one puts her best effort forward
and doesn't win thank you gentlemen
thank you
i do feel an overwhelming sense of
gratitude for having been able to
participate
mace made the better blade
and i'm proud of him
mace congratulations woo
nice
fantastic i mean the steel's beautiful i
like how you did the file work on the
blade the blade held up beautifully the
edge is razor sharp should be
exceptionally proud of that piece he had
a great job
i'm the fortune fire champion i feel
good
and i'm glad it came out on top i'm the
tiger
[Music]
you